- A lot of people consider mini golf
to be very benign and
all fun and games but,
at this level, it can be
a cutthroat competition
among the greatest players in the world.
My name is Matt Male.
I'm a professional mini golfer.
I was a regular golfer
ever since childhood.
I started at about eight years old
and putting was always the
greatest facet of my game.
The idea of doing nothing
but putting for 18 holes
instantly appealed to me and I just began
practicing a lot.
People don't realize that mini golf
is a highly precise sport.
Improvement can come very tediously.
To be competitive, it really requires
an extensive mapping of each hole
and we can be out here for
up to 10 hours a day or so,
for several days, before a tournament.
When I first arrive at a course,
I diagnose the holes.
I want to come up with a clear
plan of attack on each hole
and then just, it's a matter
of repetition from there.
We are at the 2016 mini golf masters
in North Myrtle Beach, South Carolina.
This tournament is the premiere event
each year in mini golf.
It draws players from all over the world.
The green jacket is the most
coveted prize in mini golf.
The competition is very fierce.
The players here are the best of the best
and it's an immense challenge because
even a stretch of five bad minutes
or 10 bad minutes can
disqualify you from contention.
Just a tiny miscue here or there can spell
major disaster on one hole.
I really do have an authentic admiration
of what the winner had to do to perform
under the pressure of
such a major tournament
because I know from
experience how hard it is.
Mini golf's not a sport for everyone.
There's constant frustration.
There's constant adversity.
It rewards patience and
it rewards determination
and it never gets old to
see the ball go in the hole.
I don't think that
thrill will ever go away.